[Music]
good evening young
thurs and madames welcome to a weekend
of mystery
and murder oh you don't scare me
wow i've never been in a mansion before
yeah look at this suit of
armor welcome to knockwood
manor i am your host stephen jameson iii
and i am your guest zack morris the only
which one of you is our radio contest
winner here she is lucky lisa
lucky nothing i dialed so many times i
broke a nail
congratulations lisa i hope you will all
enjoy
our murder mystery weekend i'm sure we
will yeah
so let's get on with it so where's the
corpse where's the body
she just walked in helen
she's pretty cute for a dead chick
i'm sure you will all enjoy playing
detective as our murder mystery
unfolds ladies and gentlemen
now that we've all met beware that as
the hours pass
someone here is going to die and it
could
be you save me slater i'm too cute to
die
[Music]
can we choose the victim the first
person to solve the mystery will win the
500
prize but remember
if you are to survive you must suspect
everyone
and trust no one
how do you do that
enough uh funeral music plays something
we can dance to
i'll play what i want pops
careful who you call pop sonny
yeah i'm the only one who can call him
pops you wimp
thank you my love will i uh be seeing
you later tonight
perhaps we perhaps no
i hope no for him and uh we for me
your ginger ale cola and mango tonic
with a kiwi twist
lisa you're gonna drink that no way girl
i'm just gonna
carry it around it matches my outfit
your drinkster
ladies why aren't you mingling let me
introduce you to our pianist
jeanette are we on a break
sydney spano i'm sure victor will play
anything you desire
for you my beauty i'd play the minute
waltz in 30 seconds
oh i would like to apologize
and i would like to rip off your little
french nose
i don't name one video
take my drink jeanette get me another
drink
quickly
you know smoking's really bad for your
health yeah and our health too
secondary smoke is deadly
[Music]
i hate to say i told you so all right
yes somebody is finally dead you're so
insensitive zack how'd he die how did he
die
well he grabbed his throat before he
croaked so i guess someone oh
he strangled himself to death
hello boys i've come to turn down the
beds i turned down the bed too the force
was better for your back
oh i'd like to make you more comfortable
uh may i fluff your pillow oh
fluff away
your needs really hot for zach come on
screech it's only a game
she's just acting oh good thing too
she's a lousy maid
zachary oh you are so adorable
dinner will be served shortly but i see
you're already having dessert
why must you torture me so
you better be careful preppy the last
guy she liked wound up dead i know
but what a way to go yeah
you